[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
América Latina y el mundo muchos se ha
hablado del mundial de Qatar del trato y
la muerte de trabajadores migrantes de
las reglas anti lgbt y de sus estrictas
restricciones sociales ha habido muchas
críticas peticiones de boicot e incluso
la cancelación de espectáculos de
artistas de talla mundial sin embargo el
presidente de la FIFA gianni infantino
dijo que es hipócrita que occidente de
elecciones de moralidad a otros mientras
que desde Qatar piden respeto a su
cultura y denuncian una campaña sin
precedentes de críticas nunca antes
recibidas por un país anfitrión
empezamos
esta primera copa del mundo en un país
árabes musulmán está despertando algunas
posturas de tinte racista orientalista e
incluso islamófoba y las redes sociales
están dando buena cuenta de ello veamos
Este vídeo en el que el periodista
investigador Robert Carter muestra como
en los estadios están empezando a
prohibir la entrada de aficionados
ingleses vestidos de cruzados en el
trino el periodista aclara que este
atuendo es ofensivo debido a la relación
del traje con la historia de violación
matanza y ocupación de tierras árabes
también hay ejemplos de América Latina
como este mexicano que se grabó Y subió
a redes entrando al aeropuerto de doha
lo hizo con una botella de tequila en la
mano esto cuando el alcohol solo Es
legal para extranjeros en locales
autorizados por lo que estos gestos son
vistos como una falta de respeto a la
legislación local
para analizar este tema en profundidad
hablamos con Susan saura ella es
periodista y filóloga y es ha estado se
han denunciando y señalando durante el
Mundial racismo contra Árabes y
musulmanes desde occidente señalando la
visión a culturas diferentes como un
otro escuchemos sus palabras Pues mira
eso la verdad como dicen no muchas veces
realmente el que se dejan entredicho es
el que insulta no le ha insultado
entonces con esa frase creo que ya se
escribe todo también está este
desconocimiento hacia lo desconocido o
hacia otro tipo de culturas pues dejan
entredicho a la persona que no quiera
quizás compartir de buena fe esas
costumbres que puedan tener otros países
o quizás no conocen realmente las
costumbres propias de su país porque si
miramos las tradiciones propias de cada
país se asemejan bastante Lo que pasa
que la gente abandona muchos mucho esa
tradición y se acomoda esta modernidad
digamos o simplemente dejar la tradición
por seguir moda y que un país diga
siendo conservador o tradicional en sus
costumbres o en su vestimenta Pues bueno
dejan entre dicho más bien la persona
que lo critica más que el criticado pero
no solo Los visitantes al Mundial de
Qatar han tenido conductas ofensivas
para la población local también hay
ejemplos de medios de comunicación que
han mostrado desprecio Como por ejemplo
en Top TV televisión británica propiedad
de Rupert murdock que causó malestar
entre musulmanes y árabes cuando la
presentadora preguntó han invitado lo
siguiente
el secretario de asuntos exteriores de
Reino Unido James cleverley dijo que los
fans gays que vayan a acatar para ver la
copa del mundo deben Mostrar respeto a
otras culturas donde por supuesto es un
crimen castigado con prisión y a menudo
acaban golpeados cuánto respeto
deberíamos mostrarle a culturas que
francamente consideramos una abominación
también hay ejemplos de ignorancia como
sucedió en esta nota de Blu radio una de
las principales emisoras de Colombia en
el titular hablan de dos hombres de la
mano que desafían a las autoridades pero
en el mismo texto en el subtítulo
aclaran que es normal ese tipo de
relación en medio oriente
Susan saura también se ha referido a
este tipo de noticias y al
desconocimiento de medios occidentales
hacia los árabes y la religión musulmana
que acaban siendo muchas veces
estigmatizados en el relato mediático
escuchemos
no paran de criticar sobre todo el hecho
de la vestimenta de la mujer o ciertas
costumbres islámicas se meten con la
religión en vez de investigar más
preguntar más el porqué de las cosas o
cómo ha progresado ese país realmente o
cómo los llevan otros países árabes o
islámicos pues se obcecan porque es
verdad que como he dicho también no el
desconocimiento al final es el que
prevalece y el que mete el miedo en todo
y el que hace generalizaciones es una
imagen genérica la que tienen del mundo
árabe y no separan a reparar no Entonces
es verdad que cuando la gente dice que
deberían cambiar te preguntas cambiar en
qué Porque la religión no lo van a
cambiar quizás la politización de la
religión que es en lo que sí a lo mejor
ha tenido un error como muchos Países
Árabes el politizar la religión pero en
llevar la religión no lo van a cambiar
yo por ejemplo voy al Vaticano he ido al
Vaticano y me he tenido que cubrir
también y por respeto Me cubro no me
pongo a insultar o entonces Bueno pues
ese ser receta y esa hipocresía de mucha
gente que incluso se ampara en que lo
que hacen es denunciarlo por la
violación de los Derechos Humanos cuando
no se dan cuenta que realmente es puro
racismo hasta aquí esta edición de
revista digital no sin antes recordar
nuestro compromiso con la defensa de los
Derechos Humanos Pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en France 24 y
France 24.com